bienvenue à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce numéro spécial rentrée nous
avons rencontré l'homme fort du
territoire il s'appelle philippe van de
maele c'est le nouveau directeur général
de l'établissement public d'aménagement
de paris saclay il est notre invité
c'est aussi la rentrée pour tous les
étudiants l'université paris saclay a
lancé le welcome road et son minibus
nous avons suivi sa tournée et enfin la
maison de l'étudiant
elle vient d'être inauguré on y retrouve
tous les services dédiés aux étudiants
nous étions présents vous allez la
découvrir et enfin notre agenda ce sera
la fin de cette émission c'est la
rentrée pour paris saclay tv et c'est
aussi votre rentrée votre première
rentrent aussi le grand vent de l
boujour bonjour alors vous êtes le
nouveau directeur général de
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay leur dire comment se passe
votre cette rentrée le bio coûtaient
très bien c'est une rentrée qui est très
dynamique et diana
c'est la deuxième rentrée officielle de
l'université de paris saclay et pour le
pea qui accompagne l'ensemble du
mouvement c'est aussi une rentrée assez
dynamique puisque pas mal de choses qui
se sont passées
weepu qui se sont livrés l'idée m'a
enfin c'est très actif mais beaucoup de
projets sont en cours mais d'autres sont
finalisés en qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir
justement ce qu'on peut retenir
aujourd'hui sur ce qui est vraiment
finaliser
c'est alors j'ai commencé plus tôt par
les transports c'est la mise en service
totale de la ligne de transport en
commun en site propre qui va de massy la
gare de massy-palaiseau jusqu'au
carrefour du christ de saclay sur saclay
et donc on a maintenant un bus en site
propre qui circulent en dehors de tout
embouteillage d'un bout à l'autre pour
desservir la totalité du sud plateau de
palaiseau donc ça c'était ouvert fin
août
c'est en service et c'est un point
important parce que la desserte en
tension en commun est un enjeu essentiel
et pour les étudiants et pour les
salariés qu'ils viennent travailler dans
différentes différentes entreprises
effectivement ça concerne tout le monde
ici sur le sur le plateau avec
l'instrument qu'il fallait le souligner
il ya aussi des grands groupes qui se
sont installés oui on a un voyage
absolument puis ça continue à partir
donc on a eu la chance d'avoir
effectivement l'ouverture à la fin du
printemps de du centre de recherche
d'edf et de d'ailleurs de son centre de
formation donc s'étaient livrés les deux
les deux bâtiments maintenance
opérationnelle les gens viennent
et près de 1500 personnes de plus qui
viennent sur le plateau qui viennent
tous les jours donc ça la voilà la vie
commence à démarrer effectivement vient
compléter ce qui existait avant et on
est vraiment dans cette dynamique
générale on a aussi par ailleurs livré
le lieu de vie pour les étudiants sur le
quartier de moulins qui est l'accueil
rajout de vie qui est fait à la fois
restauration lieu des changes d'accueil
et lieux sportifs parce que j'ai été
choisi une architecture particulière où
on a émis sur le toit un certain nombre
d'équipements sportifs des terrains de
basket notamment
et donc voilà ça c'est vrai que ça a
tourné on est dans cette dynamique
générale et je m'en réjouis et on est
aussi dans la partie où l'on lance de
nouveaux projets
kiki et qui avance sur l'ensemble sur
l'ensemble du territoire de paris saclay
il ya le projet de satory qui maintenant
une phase une face presque de
finalisation du projet avec avec les
élus locaux
donc c'est versailles cette souris là
c'est versailles satory gisements
importants importante c'est là toute la
zone du convoi d'ailleurs très bien ici
sur la maquette qu'est la zone du sud
plateau qui est sur l'essonne et qui est
le principal coeur de l'université de
paris saclay mais l'inertie de
paris-saclay c'est aussi bien l'essonne
ce qu'il ya dans la vallée historique
c'est l'université de paris-sud orsay
mais également l'université de
versailles saint quentin et
et les sites qui sont autour des gares
de guyancourt et de satory donc ses
études avancées on devrait pouvoir là
aussi maintenant rentrer dans les phase
plus active sur ou plus opérationnels
sur sur ces territoires yvelinois alors
vous relever de nombreux défis
oussad le ps il ya notamment cette
notion de ville durable avec des projets
très concrets qui sont menées notamment
à un réseau géothermique là aussi ça
avance bien qu'en absolument on est on
va où devrait finaliser pour ce conseil
migration l'ensemble des aspects
juridiques du réseau des changes de
chaud et de froid alors c'est un un
réseau jeudi par réseau de chaleur
réseau très particulier qui est très
effectivement liés au développement
durable puisque on table sur les changes
de chaud et de froid entre les
différents bâtiments et l'accompagnement
par une source d'énergie géothermique et
donc les effectivement les permis de
construire sont des marelles elle est
alors que les enquêtes liées aux pluies
au puits géothermiques sont en cours
donc voilà on rentre là aussi dans une
phase opérationnelle
l'année scolaire qui arrivait quand même
une année qui va être très très marquée
d'événements importants
il ya aussi tout ce qui est
développement économique là vous avez un
rôle à jouer
comment vous comptez dynamiser
l'activité économique sur le territoire
et coûté ya ya ya
effectivement quand ces démonstrations
nous à nouveau chargé d'animer
l'ensemble des acteurs de développement
économique parce qu'il ya effectivement
beaucoup d'acteurs c'est un territoire
très larges allées d'agglomération les
départements la région mais aussi l'état
et on devrait créer d'ici le mois
d'octobre un bureau développement
économique ici qui va accueillir des
personnels de l'établissement public
mais aussi de l'état et de aida chambre
de commerce et de régionalisme ce fruit
de paris pour avoir ici un pôle
partenariale pour assurer cette
animation est développée alors il ya
beaucoup d'accidents un axe important
vers l'international avec notamment les
les partenaires que son business france
la région et les chambres de commerce
il ya un travail très important qu'on
lance aussi d'animations de toutes les
établissements qui sont présents sur le
site pour voir quels sont les services
qu'ils aimeraient à voir comment on peut
réfléchir à l'avenir pour améliorer les
services que ce soit pour les
entreprises en termes de livraisons en
termes de d'amélioration de le confort
que ce soit pour les salariés
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent sur un sur
sept villes où ces nouveaux quartiers
qui se développe parce que c'est aussi
important parce que c'est pas
développement un aménagement qu'on fait
c'est une nouvelle ville c'est d'être
nouveau lieu de vie
donc c'est un aspect important qui est
qu'ils développent et puis on a un axe
très fort cocon coanime avec
l'université de paris saclay qu'est tout
ce qui tournait autour de l'innovation
les startups les lieux d'accueil on
devrait prochainement lancer nous mêmes
là
la construction de ce qu'on appelle
l'ipea choc est pas un très très beau
long incubateurs pépinières hôtel
d'entreprises pour pouvoir permettre
d'accueillir l'ensemble des start up et
puis développé et est aussi lancer une
vraie dynamique pour relier ces start up
avec les grands groupes industriels qui
peuvent être leurs clients mais aussi
avec les financeurs est ce que le gros
la grosse le gros enjeu quand on aime
start-up sédiments de trouver des
financeurs qu'ils soient prêts à vous
accompagner
donc voilà un peu la dynamique générale
son développement économique d'accord
donc un axe fort sur l'innovation et la
concertation était importante
alors pour s' est alors il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de projets qui sont lancés pour
cette saison 2016 2017 mais vos primes
aux priorités
quelles sont-elles pour les projets il
ya déjà finalisé l'ensemble des projets
en jeu pour remonter très en amont sur
les projets urbains donc finaliser le
projet de satory on a lancé
le travail partenarial sur le projet
urbain de guyancourt donc ça aussi c'est
une démarrage puis ensuite on traîne
très opérationnelle ben les différents
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
et de recherche sont en cours de
lancement de travaux ou de réalisation
ne le principal étant centrale supélec
qu'on voit vraiment les bâtiments sortir
le msk change va lancer prochainement
ses travaux de même que la situe même
télécom donc on est vraiment dans cette
dynamique d'installation
beaucoup d'établissements de logements
étudiants résidence de logements
étudiants sont partis ou sont là aussi
au début des travaux et surtout on est
dans une première phase où on sort de
cet aspect purement universitaire pour
entrer dans la nasse et plus urbain
puisque le premier programme de
logements devraient vraiment passé dans
une phase opérationnelle notamment dans
la phase vente puisque les premiers
logements vont être mis en vente en vefa
à partir de l'automne et c'est le
premier coeur de ville sur le kart sur
gif qui va se créer avec des logements
des logements étudiants bien sûr mais
aussi des commerces un maïs centrale
donc c'est vraiment la première partie
13 vies urbaines qui va qui va
maintenant se lancer et je crois que
c'est aussi un beau défi que nous avons
devant nous très bien à beaucoup de
défis à relever merci philivan de mal
d'avoir accepté notre invitation par
exemple avoir été présent d'avoir
répondu présent pour ce premier numéro
de paris saclay t2 la saison alors vous
avez dû peut-être voir le petit bus de
welcome road qui a été lancée par
l'université paris saclay donc je vous
propose de vous y emmener dans ce bus
volonté qui en fait il a sillonné le
territoire pour aller à la rencontre des
étudiants pour les informer pour
répondre à leurs questions aussi nous
avons suivi donc cette tournée de
welcome road
le welcome hôtelière sté paris-saclay
c'est une tournée d'entrée on est depuis
le 23 août
on va à la rencontre des étudiants et
des équipes sur le terrain donc dans
l'ensemble des établissements
d'universités paris saclay on va
présenter l'université les opportunités
qui sont offertes aux étudiants
on va aussi leur présenter des
événements en rapport avec leur
formation et on fait ça jusqu'au 26
novembre
voilà donc c'est vraiment une tournée
dans l'ensemble des établissements on
s'inscrit à 2 ans s'inscrit dans
différentes configurations par exemple
aujourd'hui on est sur un événement qui
est un stand de l'association donc là
enceinte d'un script notre stand a pris
à d'autres événements où on est par
exemple comme ce soir à centrale supélec
où on va il course caritative après
notre stand donc c'est toujours ainsi
qu'en mai stand on a aussi une petite
camionnette août leur demi heure c'est
qu'ils s'installent en fonction derrière
et on a de la documentation expression
des étudiants on va les voir où ils
viennent nous voir voilà et on a des
échanges avec eux non sans méfiance sont
tous au point est resté bas et saclay
fonds différents de raison donc c'est
s'inscrit sur les faces de la carte
étudiante sa plainte soit depuis
plusieurs années donc ils font vieux
projet se mettre en place
alors après le niveau d'information à
ses différents selon qu'on est là aussi
pour justement les sensibiliser
davantage encore sa l'information quand
ils en ont déjà
et en fonction de leur niveau
d'information par exemple pour ceux qui
s'intéressent au masters leur présenter
plus précisément notre propre de master
mutualisé jusqu'ici l'opération est un
franc succès on a fait quasiment une
trentaine de dates du ski si on a touché
plus de mille étudiants
pour ce cas un bon score les finances
sont ravis nous voir ils sont contents
qu'on vienne chez eux leur apporter de
l'information
elles étaient des animations aussi comme
un photocall où ils repartent avec une
photo voilà donc ils sont ravis ils ont
des petits cadeaux et premier
informations pour qui c'est la sphère
très bien
si vous êtes étudiant mois ci chez vous
nous sommes à la maison de l'étudiant
c'est un tout nouvel espace est ouvert à
guyancourt
vous y trouverez tous les services dont
vous avez besoin que ce soit logement la
santé
il ya aussi des activités culturelles
sportives tout a été conçu pour vous
regarder
ce bâtiment maison le vécu dian donc a
été pensé pour être un lieu pour
l'ensemble des associations étudiantes
mais également pour réunir tous les
services qui on a trait à la vie
étudiante dès leur arrivée à
l'université
au rez-de-chaussée donc c'est toute la
partie donc salle de représentation du
théâtre du cinéma des séminaires la
salle de multi activités pour le sport
et puis vous avez la salle d'arts
plastiques pour tous les ateliers de les
sculptures atelier peinture et dessin
tous les services que les étudiants
peuvent trouver dans cette maison de
l'étudiant s'est aussi bien donc le
service du sud services universitaires
donc de médicale de prévention de la
promotion de la santé
donc tous les étudiants pourront venir à
ce service et avec leur carte vitale
donc avoir leur visite médicale il ya
également le service d'orientation et
d'insertion professionnelle
le service d'accompagnement des
étudiants en situation de handicap le
service de la saison de social du crous
le bureau des enquêtes et analyses et
puis au premier étage on a tout service
de la vie étudiante les relations
internationales et bien sûr toute la
pépinière associative et chaque chaque
association qui a agréé qui a fait une
demande de bureaux un bureau avec une
réserve tous les nouveaux étudiants dont
qui arrivent à l'université viennent
directement à la maison de l'étudiant
pour donc finaliser leur inscription
administrative
généralement ces inscriptions
administratives se font par internet
mais il
ou quelques difficultés donc qui
viennent de finaliser leur inscription
et lorsqu'il arrive sur cette maison
d'étudiants ils ont l'ensemble des
services puisque le service de la vie
étudiante leur a mis en place un guichet
unique sur ce guichet unique y trouve
tous les services aussi bien les
mutuelles que des coûte donc un service
bancaire
l'office de tourisme donc de 51 me jean
donc vraiment tous les services utiles
le service logement également qui est là
donc pour répondre à des étudiants
français des étudiants étrangers qui
sont à la recherche aussi de logements
c'est la rentrée tous à vos agendas
voici les grands évènements à retenir
dans les semaines qui viennent
votre territoire évolué venez vous
informer et surtout donner votre avis
une concertation préalable à l'enquêté
publique pour l'amélioration de
l'échangeur de courbes ville aura lieu
entre le lundi 12 septembre et le 14
octobre 2007 à retenir aussi cet avis d'
enquête publique relatif à la recherche
d'un gîte géothermique basse température
halal bien et à l'ouverture des travaux
de forage dans le quartier de moulon il
se tiendra du lundi 19 septembre au
vendredi 21 octobre inclus même sujet
mais cette fois dans le quartier de
lavaux ville est prévue du jeudi 22
septembre au lundi 24 octobre inclus
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission la
première de la rentrée merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi pour plus d'information
notre site eps.fr merci est resté sur
terril 78